the ashes of a luxury car collection
a hummer
a lamborghini
and a cadillac
said to be the only one in sri lanka
they were just looking for the vehicles
the luxury vehicles and it was actually
a well organized
robbery people get jealous when you have
luxury cars
the wedding venue was targeted in a
night of rage against the government
a night of attacks on properties the mob
believed to be connected to the
country's ruling rajapaksa family
that's something the hotel manager
denies
he said up to 2 000 people were involved
taking everything from toilets to
teaspoons
there's no easy way for this country to
move on from this level of destruction
and this level of hatred towards not
only people with money but also the
president gotta buy a ruja puxer
[Applause]
so instead of healing tension is
building
[Applause]
protests ignited by the economic crisis
now fueled by the hundreds of arrests
for arson and violence
violence that was sparked by this
rajapaksa supporters attacking peaceful
demonstrators
so far only a handful of them have been
arrested
and that's led to accusations of police
bias
this investigation should be impartial
should be transparent i think those
things are lacking that's the thing
nineteen-year-old prabhad madashan was
filmed near a burning car on the night
of violence
he's now in jail awaiting trial
his mother sanjawani says her son was
just one of thousands on the streets
that night
look at the number of people who went to
see the protests
and see if there's room in our prisons
for all of them she told me
the attack on this luxury hotel is still
being investigated
the new prime minister has ordered a
report into the assault on
anti-government protesters in the
capital
but against a backdrop of the financial
crisis
there's no quick fix for the divisions
in the country
nicole johnston sky news colombo